I kept finding out about these female
inventors and then I would research them
or these female business owners and I
would research them I'd be like okay
thank you these smarty pants female
business owners oh my God all of them
their husband
most of the war that's the crazy thing I
couldn't believe it I was like okay this
next I would find one chick I would be
like okay this chick has to be the
smarty pants were looking for this woman
they say that women are smarter than men
I think they make up these studies I
really do I think they make up these
studies I think they make up these IQ
tests to make women feel like we do more
than we actually do